[音楽]
ちょっと話をしますと私歴史コンサルタント株式会社グース後部の代表取締役こうやっ
ております歴史学者なんです
こんな見た目だけでも嬉しい学者です大丈夫これから言うことを信じて大丈夫です
でちょっと今日はですね私の過去についてお話ししたいと思っています
私小学校からそうですね小学校1年生から歴史がものすごく好きでした
歴史が好きで好きでずっと勉強していたら小学校3年生ぐらいの時にですね
自分で大学入試な
問題を買ってきて歴史世界史日本史もそこら辺全部
得ぐらいむちゃくちゃ好きだったんですむちゃくちゃ好きだったんですが夜中の風たり
むっちゃくちゃきつかったんですね
小学校の先生は私に言うんです私と酷似なんでたまに気が向いたときにしか行かないん
ですけど
歴史ばっかりやってそんなの社会のに何の役にも立たないと言われるんですね
中学校に住んでたまに k 6で学校行くんです
担任が社会科の先生だったんですがお前歴史なんかは社会に出ても何年も経たないかな
言われ続けたんですねあまつさえ親でさえいました
うちの父親が歴史学なんか絶対許さない
うた後は無職だったんですけど
なああのそそれに比べれば僕マシな気がするんですけども
親の意向組んでですね私はあの高校は理系クラス化け学を専攻します
大学受験も理工学部に行きました
なんですけれども10代の時やっぱり
歴史が好きですでしょうがなくて埋蔵文化財の発掘調査のアルバイトをずっとしてい
ました
あれはすごく楽しいんですまあ図面引くでしょ
図面引いたりとかもしますし自分で掘ったりするそうすると歴史の例えば
教科書とかに出ている
そういったものは自分の手でまず一番訴訟の第一発見者は自分なんですね
過去と自分とをつなぐも乗っ触れました
やっぱり歴史をやりたいと思ったんですがなかなか機会がなくてその後会社を経営し
たりとかを経てですね26歳の時に大学1年生として大学にはおり入りなおします
みんなよりも約10歳
ない年上の役に老けた新入生だったんですけどもそこで一番最初に私が勉強したいと
思ったコールドしたものを立洋楽というものです
まあいわゆる縫製しですけれども律令学
律令て何かって言うとですね奈良時代ぐらいに中国の方から入れてきた
社会政治システムと思ってもらえたらいいと思います
立留学勉強した思ったのは日本という土地はですね
よく言われるんです日本にオリジナリティがない
いろんな外側からの受け売りのものばっかりだと言われるんですけれども
でも実際に勉強してみるとまた印象が違いました
例えば中国には宦官という存在ます
去勢した男性ですねまあ雑用なんかをしたりですとかうまくいくとですね
皇帝の矜持になったりですとかあとは高級に使えたりなんかするんです
なんですが日本の率を入れたときにはその考えに対する規定がない
つまり日本人は宦官というのは嫌だ去勢させた
音声なんて作りたくないっていうのを自ら選択したわけですよね
ということは律令法をやっていた疑問を持ったんです
その前や価値観があるプレイ律令という存在があるんじゃないかと思いました
そして先生の許可をもらって高校役にも顔を出すようになりその後どうやって法律が今
の段階になっていくのかというので縫製しも研究をしました
運がよく私は大学2年生の時に今言います公益社団法人うんこ学会
花を基地史料館の研究員に抜擢してもらいました異例の抜てきでした
もうこれは絶対人は教授になるんだと投資こいてました
調子こいて大学院に進んだんですが大学に進んだ
その1カ月前に日本を揺るがす大事件が起こりました
東日本大震災です
絵がし日本大震災が起こって
大学院行ってみると何にも変わらない日常があるのです
そう当時私はテレビ局 tbs テレビというところで働いていました
毎日連日連夜余震が続き死傷者数が増えていく
報道ですからもうフルに回ってるんです
そういう中で
仕事をしてそして大学院に行くと何も変わらない人主張がある
この現実の乖離私はショックを受けました
表向きには体調不良という点ですか本当は嫌で嫌でその帰りが嫌で嫌で私は大学院を
タイプしました
その間思っていたのが一番最初の小学校中学校ずっと言われ続けてげてきた言葉です
歴史なんかやって何の意味があるのということです
ずっと自問自答し続けましたそして今年一つの答えとして
歴史でもって世の中の課題ですとか問題に対して
answer を出せるそんなものがあってもいいんではないか
むしろそういう和篤どうしていくべきだろうと思いまして私は株式がシャークスコーブ
という会社を設立たんです
私は過去のさまざまなそうした自分自問自答の中で答えを持ちようになりました
歴史って役に立つのか
答えはですね no ですね役に立ちませんね
というよりは厳密にいうと何となく勉強したものなんて絶対に役に立つわけがないん
です
皆さん歴史はなんとなく勉強してましたよねだから役に立たないんですそれはいろんな
すべての学問に対して言えることだと思うんです
ではなぜ歴史学だけが特に名指しをされて言われてしまうのかを考えると
一番最初に歴史を勉強した時に年号や人名などを覚えさせられますよね
でも本当に一番最初に勉強するのはなぜ歴史を学ぶ意味があるのかということを
問いかける
このことが一番小学には必要なことだと私は思うんです
それは
この後にも登壇されますけれども福本さん東大東大先端研と日本剤ではロケットという
プロジェクトがありますけど私はその外部高所
させていただいてますその中でも子どもたちに遺憾なく自分なりには伝えているつもり
なんです
そして歴史というとよくいわれることがあります
歴史は繰り返されるそんなことないですね
歴史は繰り返さないです大丈夫ですなぜならば時代が違うんですから人も違います状況
も違いますテクノロジーも違います
全ての条件が違うんだから同じ事なんか起こり得るわけがないんです
起こり得るわけじゃないんですが起こったように
三重
似たような塾ことはやはり起こるんです似たようなことが起こった時に私たちは何が
必要なのか
私たち歴史家の視点夜中に対して言えることは何なのか
それを考えてみるとやはり因果関係ある歴史的事象から因果関係をちゃんと構えると
いうことそして本質一体その本質は何があったのかと本質をとらえることそれを使う
ことによって現在に対するアンサーができると思うんです
イスラム法学者にファズルラ不満という人がいます
こういうのは20理論というのを立てるんですけれどもあるくるわー
の中から物事のいいが関係た放出を
だしてきてそれを現代に当てはまるようにもう追走を変え直すというやり方で
イスラームというのは現在も使えるフレームなんだということをまあ提示している学者
さんなんですね
私はそうのファズルラ不満のやり方清めてこれは歴史学度は普通に使われているやり方
なのですが私はこのやり方で何か世の中に役に立てないかと思ってるんだ
これからの世の中未来というのは非常に難しい時代です
アッチェレランドという言葉がありますこれは音楽用語で次第に速く
という意味なんですけれどもこれからの未来というのはもう
予想ができないくらいに変化を速くなっていきます
2050年のことたかだか33年
33ねなんてね33年後のことでされ私たちはもう予測することが実はできないぐらい
にどんどんの技術が果たしているんです
フランスの詩人で小説家フランスの第3期共和国土日の巨人と呼ばれた人にポール
ヴァレリーという人がいます
ポールヴァレリーと人の精神の政策という
まあ短編の中に一番最後のとこにこういう言葉は書いてあります
私たちは後ずさりしながら未来入るという言葉を書いてあります
これはどういう意味なのかというと
あとざり歴史を見ながら私たちは後ろ向きに未来に入っていくんだという意味です
未来というのは実はとても恐ろしいです難波やってくるか全然予想ができません
何が飛び出してくるのかが全く分からない先の見えない真っ暗なトンネルといっしょの
です
ですが私たちは未来をいなければいいじゃないその時に過去ふと振り返るんです
そうすると私たちのきた道はちゃんと光がありますそれを見ながら私たちは後ろ向きに
行く
私はそういう生き方でいいんではないかと思ってます
実際株式相場の相場師でさえ
過去のデータがなかったら未来なんて予想できないんです
未来を見たければ私は過去を見ようそして現在の問題に対して
過去歴史というものが大きな示唆を与えてくれる自分の人生経験が増えればその分だけ
歴史に対する理解も深くなります
そうした人繋がり飲もうとしてれ希少トライそして
歴史学のチー僕の子供のときのように
あんなもの役に立たないなんて言われない夜中にしていきたいなと思って私はそういう
試みをしているんです
オチはありません後ずさりしながら去っていくことにしましょう
皆さんありがとうございました
[拍手]